John: Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday, May
5th, 2015, your 35th birthday!
It's just ridiculously beautiful here—Haaank!
Oh look, it's Hank!
Hank is of course using this occasion to Snapchat.
John: Don't rock.
Hank: Yeah!
John: It's going to ruin the shot.
Hank: Whee!
John: Oh, it's going to make people sick to
their stomachs.
Hank: Whee!
John: When your birthday falls on a Tuesday,
it is a great present to me, because it means
I don't have to make an extra Vlogbrothers
video.
Thank you.
Hank: Well, if you could work out that for
me on…August 27th…
John: Oh my God you've hurt my feelings!
Let's move on, it's twenty—August twenty—
Hank: 23rd?
John: I don't even wanna be your friend anymore,
let alone your sibling.
I have not gotten you a formal present.
Instead, I want to tell you that I will get
you anything you want.
Hank: I want a whole mountain.
John: I cannot buy you a mountain.
I don't have the resources.
Hank: What about a project?
John: Depends on the project.
I don't wanna do a project that I don't wanna
do.
Hank: What a surprise.
John: But it is your birthday.
Hank: John Green: doesn't wanna do things
he doesn't wanna do.
John: I have a longstanding opposition to
doing things that I don't wanna do.
Hank: I've wanted to do a podcast with you.
John: Oh!
I like podcasts.
What should it be about?
Hank: Stuff that we care about.
Stuff that we like.
John: Mm, that's going to bore people.
I really like high-concept podcasts like Night
Vale, or the DeGeorges have that podcast that's
from the perspective of a cephalopod.
Hank: It's a giant squid, yeah.
John: Yeah.
Hank: Do you want to ask?
John: Oh!
Oh, yeah.
What should we make a podcast about?
By the way, I don't know why we're not making
our video with that in the background.
Hank: I mean, I could explain it.
It has to do with—
John: It has to do with lighting.
Hank: The lighting.
John: So as Hank's birthday present, I am
going to get him a podcast, uh, that we make.
Hank: Starring us.
John: It's starring us, but you guys tell
us what it should be about.
Hank: I like the idea of…I just had this
one.
John: Okay.
Hank: What if, uh, every episode we just talk
about a different person, but we pick a name,
and we just talk about a person with that
name in history.
John: Oh, so like the, oh, so it's like "The
Steve Podcast with John and Hank Green."
Hank: Yeah.
John: Or like "The Sydney Podcast."
Like, something gender-neutral.
Hank: But it should be two names so that people
are extra confused.
John: Oh, like, the, uh—
Hank: Like "The Sydney and Jesse Podcast—"
John: "With John and Hank Green."
Hank: "With John and Hank Green."
John: And we just talk about Sydneys and Jesses.
But there should be another, there should
be another thing.
Hank: There's, yeah yeah, segments where we
talk about other stuff we're into, and also
what's going on in our lives or things.
John: I'll do like "This Week in AFC Wimbledon."
Like, what's going on in fourth-tier football.
Hank: Right, because everybody's so interested
in that.
John: Everyone is.
Well what is something that you care about?
Hank: I could do Mars, 'cause I've cared about
that forever.
John: "This week in Mars and AFC Wimbledon!"
The—
Hank: And Mars is so much more interesting
than AFC Wimbledon, so everyone will listen
for Mars, we have to do AFC Wimbledon first,
so people have to sit through it to get to
the Mars news.
John: Strongly disagree.
Mars is a planet that humans can't inhabit;
AFC Wimbledon is a club made out of humans.
And aren't humans the most interesting thing
in the world, really?
Hank: He says as he points the camera just
at himself.
John: Whose birthday is it anyway?
It's my birthday, right?
Isn't it August 27th or 22nd?
No one can remember.
I'm not sure it's sustainable, are there enough
Sydneys and Jesses?
Hank: Oh, sure.
John: Name two Sydneys.
'Cause—"
Hank: My mom, Sydney Green.
Sydney, Australia?
John: Ah.
Is there a Jesse, Australia?
If you like this idea, let us know some Sydneys
and Jesses in comments.
Oh no, it, it's leaving me.
Was that your Blue Steel?
On three, uh, our best Blue Steel.
One, Two, Three.
So we need you to tell us what our podcast
is going to be about, if it's going to be
about Sydneys and Jesses, some Sydneys and
Jesses we can talk about, who has the best
Blue Steel, and if AFC Wimbledon or Mars is
more important.
Hank: Right.
John: Would the earth be different if there
were no Mars?
Hank: I mean, yes?
John: How?
Hank: We, well—
John: The sky would look different at night,
but if there were no AFC Wimbledon, the core
of human history would change.
Hank: [Burps] So also for my birthday.
John: Yeah?
Hank: I have to make a video this week.
John: Yes.
Hank: I would make, like to make that video
a, a kind of, uh, Vlogbrothers Olympics.
John: I may do it.
Hank: Where you and I compete in, in events.
John: How many events?
Hank: Twenty.
John: No!
Hank: It's going to be a dodecacathlon.
What about like a, no, like a septathlon,
or maybe a quadragocon.
Hank: Okay, "quadragocon" I will go for.
John: So we're doing a four event quadragocon.
Hank: No no no, fourteen.
Quadragocon is fourteen.
Obviously.
The first event is who wins that Blue Steel.
John: Okay.
Hank: Okay.
John: Hank, Happy Birthday.
I will, uh, see you, I will continue to see
you after I turn off the camera.